[Music]
someone told me that you were kind of a
goth kid growing up a lot yes very much
so
how Goffe were you I was so got there
there's no joke for that how coffee I
was well I was kind of obsessed with The
Addams Family and I went through a phase
where I thought I was Wednesday Addams
and I would introduce myself as
Wednesday The Strangers oh I would sleep
like this it was that's sad
straight drama I was very dramatic
no it's it all worked out now but that
must have been scary for your parents
like when you go through a phase like
that care oh I was their fifth child
exactly I was one of six okay they were
like whatever you do what you want to do
your final again yeah and if you came in
and said we just two of them just got
lost on the freeway there's more I think
we have a picture of you when you were a
kid that now this this is quite Goffe
right here I love the expression - look
how committed I was oh the veil of
darkness and please tell me that was
Halloween is that was that Halloween
actually was oh good
it's gonna say this is you off the
church yeah I'm going to echo God
you